bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono farisei e
oggi siamo di nuovo su scrive il sun
limited prima di farlo però volevo
ancora fare una cosa allora mi avete
avevo detto nello scorso episodio che
potevate consigliarmi degli oggetti
delle cose divertenti da creare
praticamente avete messo circa 6 o 700
commenti io mi sono veramente spaventato
detto minchia come faccio praticamente
ragazzette in troppi cioè impossibile
pensavo che di avere che ne sono una
cinquantina tra un centinaio di dema 700
e una cosa assurda la più richiesta
non che avessi dubbi era quella dello
slam germain però io non ho specificato
una cosa quando l'ho spiegato
praticamente si possono creare gli
oggetti ma non quelli coperti da
copyright o vero non i nomi propri
alcuni hanno scritto tipo il titanic che
ne so non posso scrivere titanic perché
non appare quindi slider man dovrei
scrivere manichino in teoria o manichino
on smoking per fare un esempio però non
posso scrivere nomi propri
la seconda più richiesta invece è stato
fa vj cioè molti di voi mi hanno chiesto
di materializzare me stesso per ora gas
e io scrivo dei nomi veri lui non può
materializzare
[Musica]
a
ok lo mi hanno rubato maledetto stronzo
insegna a pescare a un mendicante non si
pesca anni fa vj e ho provato anche a
creare lowes lander mano che è perfetto
lander man mia uscito un po così però
dai un pochettino ci somiglia parte gli
occhi che in teoria non ha la faccia
però è un po diciamo in anime dovrebbe
essere più che ne so magari vivo
ecco perfetto ok oh cazzo b o per che
cammina all'indietro e tipo gambero
perfetto mancava l'aggettivo giusto
pedofilo ok adesso dovrebbe funzionare o
petrò fino cioè trono fino ok non è
proprio la stessa cosa però va beh più o
meno e va beh direi basta a cazzeggiare
lo slider man si divertirà per i cazzi
suoi
mi avete detto anche di scrivere st
wright però non penso che funzioni st
wright cazzo funziona solo che
evidentemente non funziona perché non è
la st wright giusta è una palese copia
made in china ok devo riuscire a
guadagnarmi questa se riesco ok inizia
rockstar da strada non so che cos'è
beh ok sono diventato punk voglio essere
una stella del rock per prima cosa ho
bisogno dello strumento migliore
che ne so uno strumento migliore per
diventare una rockstar xilofono bene vai
divertiti
questo strumento è magnifico la mia band
sarebbe molto meglio con ulteriori
membri
ok allora facciamo così per uno xilofono
ci vorrà una band giusta
ac acido no vabbè allora il gruppo busi
musicamica non so scrivere ragazze
musicale per john lennon perfetto ti ho
creato john lennon un pagliaccio un
eschimese questa sì che una band ora
abbiamo bisogno dell'apparecchiatura
permette al suo vero spettacolo è ok
mancava arisa e poi whitney houston
abbiamo per l'apparecchiatura direi che
ne so casse case casse per cassano cassa
audio perfetto un po più grande sarebbe
l'ideale però va bene così
ok perfetto quella cassa dovrebbe deve
essere veramente potente sa casa mi
dicono allora ok raccogli perfetto
perfetto quarta st wright ho notato raga
che quello sul palco dovrebbe essere
justin bieber con un cappello con un
berretto questo qui però vabbè poche
domande andiamo avanti
ok non so cosa devo fare la gaver a
mente questa una st wright mi piace
aiuta a migliorare il quartiere
ok basta con il vecchio ma che vuol dire
è tempo di migliorare il quartiere
comincia demolendo questo vecchio
edificio mi piace mi piace allora palla
demolitrice ok palla no da demolizione
forse da demolizione
se però o cazz o che cazzo
ok dato che non so cosa creare facciamo
alla vecchia maniera perché sennò
facciamo così bong nucleare così siamo
sicuri che che va giù
tra l'altro mi avete detto non l'avete
consigliata anche di farla però non è
proprio l'esatto non è proprio il
consigliabile pro proviamoci
non è esplosa forse sarebbe meglio non
ci penso io ci penso io ma ho vinto ce
l'ho fatta da una nuova struttura deve
essere costruita sul terreno libero crea
luogo che piace ai cittadini discarica
discarca perfetto discarica luogo ok
questo piace perfetto
sono contento che apprezzi le mie
costruzioni perfetto adesso che avete la
discarica bella genuina e il giorno
dell'inaugurazione fai sapere in giro
che è pronto nuovo edificio che cazzo è
quella roba
cos'è sta roba
andate a vivere nella discarica perfetto
barbon styles dove devo ok adesso che vi
ho creato questo bellissimo habitat in
cui vivere me l'ha data è stasta write
ama e via terra non avevo visto che è
perfetto no
minchia pensavo di distruggerla mi ero
preso malissimo
raccogli se si fa vj benefattore crea
edifici splendidi per tutti ok
devo riuscire ad andare via di qui
perchè devo cos'è una galleria questa
c'è questa qui che innamorata vorrei che
qualcuno mi desse qualcosa di romantico
come nei film
facciamo che san valentino da ieri
allora scatola di cioccolatini perfetto
che io amo scrive l'ansa ok io non mi
chiamo scrive lo sfidiamo fa vj ma
apprezzo il gesto grazie mille allora
adesso voi mi spiegate perché anche nel
film ha dato alla scatola di
cioccolatini e mi spiegate perchè io
sono vestito da omino hamburger però
lasciamo perdere
ok non mi piaceva come costume meno
rimetto ok perfetto
direi che possiamo uscire di qua ra che
io amo scrivere non so veramente
fantastico giuro
cos'è questo aiuta il ragazzo con il suo
appuntamento galante ci penso io sono fa
vj ma mi chiamano cupido il ragazzo sta
andando a un appuntamento speciale con
la sua ragazza aiuta la farà andare
tutto liscio per prima cosa rendilo
presentabile facciamo la facciamo così
direttamente usa bocca punti crea
aggettivo bello bello
ok adesso sei bello perfetto cosa ha
aggiunto un cappello alla professor
layton questo è l'ideale di bello
ok adesso sei diventato un gangster
perfetto ma chi è quella bello il
ragazzo ma non può presentarsi senza un
veicolo con cosa dovrebbe passare a
prenderla minchia che in occa vabbè
lasciamo perdere
cosa può passare a prenderla dato che
gli abitanti di questa città sembra
piacere tanto la discarica facciamo
camion della spazzatura
ok vai vai romanticone perfetto quale
ragazza non vuole essere rimorchiata con
un camion dei rifiuti a lei piaceva
questo pericolo
ma lui non può arrivare a mani vuote da
te di qualcosa per cominciare la serata
in modo migliore
allora facciamo i romanticoni come si
deve per una volta mazzo di rose a caso
proprio ammazzo ds mazzo di magro di s
magro s s è perfetto ma che allora mazzo
di fiori se non gli piace di fuori marzo
di fuori di fiori ok
vai così fai vedere chi sei perfetto
ok bene bellissimo
l'appuntamento sembra andar bene crea
qualcosa per rendere la cena più
romantica
allora facciamo allora in questi casi ci
sta una scimmia ammaestrata cimici mia
scimmia perfetto firmi ammalata ok
vai così non è romantica questa cenano
perfetto la facciamo
candela una bella candela di fuoco è la
cosa più romantica che mi viene in mente
in questo momento vai così che l'ho
presa io però non devo prenderla io
prima che va tutto a fuoco spegne ok
perfetto
non so che non volevo crearli io volevo
crearli io e mucciaccio se non è valido
devo prendere l'arco perché se no non
sono cupido perfetto adesso cosa andate
a fare di bello non voglio sapere cosa
stanno andando a fare li dentro
ok state uscendo ai bei film ci sta
giustamente mi viene da piangere quasi
si è fantastico che bello ragazzi sta
per chiederle la mano magari lei
accetterà la risposta si è di che hanno
di che hanno bisogno per la cerimonia
allora facciamo prete vai col prete che
sposa la gente vai così e vi dichiaro ma
facevo io e prete e vi dichiaro marito e
moglie perfetta grazie a fa vj ancora
una volta la storia d'amore ha avuto un
senso st wright serata romantica
perfetto 7 st wright minchia sta andando
velocissimo continua le ho prese
praticamente quasi tutte nella città
adesso io in questa puntata volevo
cambiare zona sono ancora vestito da un
rubino dell'hamburger perfetta elimina
adesso che sei felice vi mancano i figli
però vabbè
l'unica cosa è il vicino di merda che
avete che non
non lo so è peggio di dean kleber che
però va beh non fa niente dovevo provare
a creare timi turner aspettate un attimo
che mi è venuta l'idea bambino con
cappello rosa bambino ragazzo si addio
non è no queste bambino rosa con
cappello non bambino che capello rosa
però vabbè più o meno vabbè comunque a
parte tutto proviamo a cliccare sul
mondo andare da qualche altra parte
sono veramente contento che gioca così
lunga da finire perché veramente mi
diverto tantissimo a giocarci alla
galleria della virgola
non l'avevo già vista mi pare andiamo
nel ristorante punto che forse è quello
di prima no perfetto benvenuta
ristorante il punto ok i nomi più strani
del mondo
allora abbiamo gordon ramsay abbiamo
jackass perché c'è un minotauro in
cucina
allora innanzitutto per una buona cucina
ci penso io perché non abbiamo l'insetto
che c'era in città questo mi perseguita
laga peggio dello slider man
c'è una puzzola con le ali ai ah ok
perfetto non posso arrivare più vicino
perché prendo fuoco però però ok dai
allo chef di ingredienti necessari a
preparare le portate per ogni cliente
ok apprendista chef apprendista chef che
è perfetto
ci penso io ci penso io ok sono ricchi a
chiazza arrivata dalla combriccola di
hogwards dai e lo chef dei con degli
ingredienti perché la di pianti differen
comincia aggiungendo tre ingredienti
hanno una pizza
allora prima di cucinare però io farei
una cosa facciamo
dopo ok adesso sono sicurissimo che
riusciremo a cucinare come si deve
perché senza la tattoo il sì però devi
devi entrare ed è sotto al mio cappello
se non riesco a cucinare va beh
facciamo senza prova a fare
prova andare senza al topo allora
facciamo ingredienti per la pizza
mozzarella ma manca la pizza prima
allora farina non so che in pace di
cucinare laga farina mozzarella
napoletana proprio quella buona
sarà fissa sarà utile per creare la
pasta per la pizza ok grazie
la mozzarella è già l'ingrediente dopo
perfetto e poi come cazzo si fa la pizza
facciamola con la facciamo non so
facciamola diavola ivi bruxelles wars
tel
ok bene già a dire tutto questo non do
vinho news il formaggio un classico
sulla maggior parte delle pizze si
dipende allora mettiamoci anche
mettiamoci anche un bel gelato che lui
prende qualsiasi qualsiasi ingrediente
io metta mettiamoci anche ha gelato la
carne un ottimo ingrediente sono io il
cuoco cui la pizza ci vuole per la pizza
ci vorrà un ingrediente segreto usa
bocca degli appunti per raggiungerlo
l'ingrediente segreto e il gelato
ragazzi il gelato è l'ingrediente
segreto di ogni pizza sembrerebbe una
pizza appetitosa perfetto no è mia e mi
ha mai detto ok ora cuoceremo una felice
una fenice per la strega aggiunge gli
ingredienti per preparare questo uccello
magico una fenice devo cuocere una
fenice fenice non si vuol dire una
fenice perché mangiatelo adesso che
cazzo
macché raga io sto gioco non lo capirò
mai aggiunge ok un tocco magico allora
un in gara aggiungere un tocco magico un
po di fia si leather be light
ok non funziona stavolta va bè facciamo
non lo so polvere di stelle
mi sembra una cosa abbastanza magica
anche polvere di mele polvere e cenere
di mele ok perfetto vai così adesso ci
siamo perfetto aggiungerà aggiungerà un
po di fuoco alla fenice
cosa devo fare ora cuoceremo una felice
per la strega aggiungere ingredienti
ancora cosa vuoi che metta
che ne so proviamo a friggerla non
colonia ma con l'aranciata annunciata ok
giustamente l'aranciata per friggere la
fenice perfetto
ok allora fenice polvere di cenere di
mele aranciata
dyou tocco di colore alla fenice
vernice rossa no è già cosa fece quindi
vernice blu perfetto
ok adesso ci dovremmo essere per abbiamo
colto una fenice però sembra ancora un
po cruda guarda è ancora dato che ancora
viva direi di sì a era viva ok perfetto
ebbene sembra che queste cose si
risolvano sempre da sole va bene mi fa
piacere è cosa cosa cosa desidera
l'ultimo clima non l'ultimo cliente
vuole conoscere una una moto metti tre
ingredienti nel forno per crearne una
allora facciamo catena ma perché devono
cuocere una moto la catena non è
esattamente quella della moto però vabbè
riempì poi facciamo
manubrio ok manubrio la guida no non è
proprio questo il manubrio che intendevo
però vabbè
ok questa è la moto più strana che abbia
mai fatto e poi ovviamente le ruote
vuota ma bensì ruota che non è
esattamente la ruota di una moto però io
sono curiosissimo di vedere che cazzo di
moto esce sarà il punto di partenza per
il telaio ok delle ruote sono già state
aggiunte prova qualcos'altro facciamo
sedile se i nomi se dall e sedile
momenti là fuori quello del cinema auto
perfetto eh sì va bene lasciamo sta in
teoria no veramente dal sellino anch'io
sono un deficiente però va bene ma
andiamo così è se vi ricordate tutti i
pezzi che ho messo provatamente
all'insieme
provate a immaginare cosa esce
permetterà la moto di funzionaria sì
certo
il guidatore avrà un posto per sedersi
sì infatti l'ho messo
ok misticamente uscita fuori una moto
quasi decente a parte il manubrio che è
uscito questa volta è troppo bella per
darla via cvc ok il call così è [ __ ]
la moto rimango soltanto io e
ratatouille che non è scappato vabbè
prendiamo la st wright e sono otto
perfetto posso sbloccarmi già la parte
nuova del mondo totale 68 incredibile
ottimo lavoro
vai da lily così almeno andiamo a vedere
che cosa ci siamo sbloccati
intanto la povera lily e lì ancora
perfetto chi è questo ok è un uno scout
è arrivato uno scout ragazzi è dov'è
ok seguiamo lo scout che vola vabbè
abbiamo delle nuove zone sbloccate però
direi che posso farle nella prossima nel
prossimo episodio
direi che possiamo chiudere qui dove
minchia siamo il castello di serkan
cancellato o cancelletto non ho letto
bene va beh c'è un boia ci sarebbe bene
jack sparrow però va beh non importa
ok degli ok sono arrivato anch'io eh va
beh direi che posso draga qua mi
divertirò come un matto però nel
prossimo episodio quindi come al solito
se il video vi è piaciuto lasciato un
commento mi piace anche la pagina
facebook e come al solito trovate nella
descrizione di ogni mio video se non
siete ancora iscrivetevi ci vediamo un
prossimo video bella ragazzi